fifteen years ago tonight malice at the
palace
Reggie Miller was in street clothes that
night did you realize it was 15 years
ago wrench I had no idea no obviously
I'm getting the Texas and the tweets and
the social media but you know I tuned in
earlier to you guys is broadcast and
when you said that I was like a spin 50
it's been 15 years since all that went
down it it's still somewhat surreal
having been there and been in the moment
of that because you flashback to you
know things you wish would have went
down I mean I wish I would have told
rick carlisle because i was as you said
mentioned i was in you know cities i was
in you know my suit i should have told
coach Carlisle you know what it's time
to get the guys out of there you know
Jermaine obviously Ron Artest
because we were up by like 15 18 points
with you know two or three minutes left
in the game it's under a minute ah yeah
we should we should have gotten the
matter but we were also trying to make a
statement this was a team that was the
defending champions they were our rivals
they had brought back obviously the same
team we had brought back the same team
but we had added Steven Jackson which
was good which was like perfect for our
mixture of guys so you know I get it
that we were trying to make a statement
on their home court that yeah you guys
are the champs and you beat us last year
in the Conference Finals to move on and
win so I get it but it got ugly real
quick Theodore I thought that Ben
Wallace kind of got off a little bit
here where you know I bet he blamed
Stephen Jackson and Jermaine and run our
test but you know Ben Wallace was you
know one of the agitators initiators in
that I was a little surprised he didn't
get the lengthy suspension that Stephen
or Jermaine got obviously ron was
suspended for the rest of the season
there was no coming back from that but I
was a little surprised at that because
what makes it so surreal
just remember after the initial rock
practice happened on the court when you
know drawn in and Ben Wallace would add
it and in those referee you know after
that was over and then Ron went and laid
on the scorer's table that's what I came
in and I was like patting Ron on his
chest saying you know all right big
fella it's over it's good and then I to
this day Theodore I can remember I see
that red cup flying in the air out of
the corner of my eye coming straight
towards us and hits Ron right in the
chest that was full of beer and it was
like The Incredible Hulk
he turned green right there and it was
like in slow motion I was like no Ron
and he burst off the scores table and
went straight into the stands and you
know I went riding after him to try to
grab him but it was too late by then
because he had his mind set up on I
don't even think he knew who through it
was he just went into the vicinity of
the Cup and that's when it all hell
broke loose and I went in after him
tried to get him and you know you know
the rest
rein and Ron of a Steven Jackson he went
into to the stands this way it was just
crazy it was absolutely crazy what was
it like though when you guys went to the
bus were you guys worried about your
safety get down to that arena what
ironic is not after that game when we
played them again and had to come to the
palace that's when the issues of safety
because people were calling in bomb
threats and there was supposed to be
hitman in assassins it was like crazy so
we had to stay on the bus I'm not
kidding you two hours we couldn't even
go into the palace the next time we came
to play the Pistons because there were
so many bomb scares and the police
presence was unbelievable but the
rivalry was real there was a lot of
respect obviously between the two teams
but the rivalry was real and I think
people were taking it to a different
level but uh certainly certainly surreal
when you think about it right now
how did that change the NBA
it changed fan interaction if you go to
NBA arenas now and you walk into each
tunnel where the players run out
you see those tarps that are hanging now
that's all because of what happened at
the palace if you remember when Chuck
person myself and Ron after we had
gotten wrong onto the court and we were
heading towards the locker room you
remember how we were being doused with
beer and coke in popcorn or whatever
well that's when the league instituted
all those tarps now because before you
would walk by and you would sign
autographs or whatever high-five you
would throw kids your arm bends or shoes
whatever now they have those tarps there
because of that I just think it took a
little bit away from the fan experience
a little bit but uh it was just unreal
going through the tunnel because we we
were just covering ourselves in just
beer and coke and whatever people
throwing coins it was as crazy trying to
get into the locker room talking to
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer and
works for Turner Sports he's on the call
with Kevin Harlan Kristen Ledlow that'll
be pelicans Suns 10:30 Eastern on TNT
coming up on Thursday James Harden the
other night scored 49 against the
Timberwolves he took 41 shots when is
what is it too much for James Hart like
is there a number where you go that's
too many shots it's working is it going
to continues it sustainable for him I
think it is sustainable you just hope he
doesn't run on a bullet right this is a
guy that says he's not he's never enter
load management if he's healthy he's
going to play and I think he needs to
play to stay within
you and I we've talked about this are
the Rockets any better than they were a
year ago when they had Chris Paul now
that they've added Russell Westbrook
there's basically a swap you do add
another MVP and a guy that you know
they're familiar with one another from
their days you know playing with and
against one another in Los Angeles I
think it is sustainable we've seen this
now for the last what five or six years
from from James Harden so we know he can
keep up the workload the thing is he's
traditionally gotten tired come what
playoff time and runs out of gas but I
think having Westbrook to kind of take
the load off of him a little bit I hope
this kind of keeps them somewhat fresh
come playoff time but we have a law I
mean look we got what another four and a
half five months of regular season
basketball
you hope he you hope he could kind of
take some a little bit of break here
that he doesn't run you know start
running on fumes here pretty soon
I saved an unbelievable run that's going
on you know I like in this looking at
him play it in today's rules in today's
game where you can't touch freedom of
movement it must be like how we felt
when we had to guard his Airness in
Michael Jordan it he's unguardable
seriously he is I'm not saying he is
Michael Jordan but in today's game if
you have to play James Harden I don't
know how you play it play him you can't
force him left you can't force them
right because he can go out of their way
he has a floater he has a step back
double step back three where he creates
separation he gets every call right so
he's getting to the line 10 to 12 times
I don't know how you guard him
I really don't well I said Ju you could
not guard MJ you could not what you
wanted to force him to shoot the jumper
MJ yeah early in his career when he came
back the first time for retirement after
he had won three I might add you he had
that jump shot he didn't have the same
bounce he had when he came back from
but he had that fadeaway he always had
that fadeaway in the post right well
when he went down here when he went down
on the block oh yeah he was will at 65
you couldn't move him and he was so
quick so when he faced you the first
step he was by you it's the same thing
with Harden he faces you up he dribbles
eight times through the legs and he he's
by you and he has the strength in his
sides to hold you long not only is he by
you but when you catch up he's so strong
he's holding you so when he's getting
ready to take the shot
you found him he's holding you and you
found him could Jordan guard harden now
with today's rules Wow how would it be a
great matchup it really would cuz you're
talking about one of the greatest
defensive players at his position ever
and MJ but in today's rules where the
physicality has gone out the window it
is it's very difficult to guard James
Harden I don't know
and once you flip it why don't you flip
it so Harding team card anybody I'm
gonna say a quick no reg harden a quick
no - I think MJ would have a better
chance of guarding Harden than harden
would having guarding their zone yeah
Paul George had 37 against the Hawks he
declared himself back hit the
game-winner against the Thunder you know
it's gonna be hard to assess this team
it feels like reg because I you know
kawaii'
is still doing the load management thing
I don't know if we'll know how good the
Clippers are until maybe after December
I know they're great or the potential
for grade but you know two guys working
together for the first time and then a
whole new team and I don't know I I'm
not sure what do you think and you add
Lou Williams to the mix and montrezl
harrell two guys coming off the bench
who are going to have to be able to work
with those other two superstars right
I don't think we're gonna get the best
picture of the Clippers to me until
really after the all-star break okay
when you get into March and April when
teams start seeing the light at the end
in the tunnel and they can start
focusing in on the playoffs I think
that's when you'll start to get regular
rotations minutes I think both of those
players will perhaps be off the load
management because they're getting ready
for the playoffs
I think what's been a little bit more
telling and upsetting for clipper fans
is the Clippers defense look I had them
as a top-ten defensive team you know
when you've got you know Paul George and
you got quite Leonard Beverly Patrick
Beverley montrezl harrell's I thought
they were going to be a much better
defensive team they're giving up way too
many points and teams are you know
shooting too well against them so
they're gonna have to be better
defensively I'm not worried about the
mixture between kalaiy and Paul George
they'll figure it out but we won't see
the best of the Clippers to me until
after the all-star break LeBron says if
he's healthy he's playing there's no
load management but if you were the
Lakers would you try to impress upon him
that we we want you to have load
management we want you to be ready for
the second half of the season certainly
at his age with that mileage is this a
smart approach by LeBron and the Lakers
it's not a smart approach and I look I
respect wood I respect what he's saying
if you if you're healthy enough to play
I always felt a 75% 80% Reggie is as
good as 100% of any of these other
jokers and I'm lining up against that's
how I always felt you've got to have
that mindset so I respect what he's
saying look to me if they take care of
business and he plays 28 to 30 minutes
and he sits out the fourth that's part
of his load management I'm sure if you
look at the schedule there's going to be
certain games on certain back-to-back
you perhaps take one away I wouldn't go
as extreme as quite Leonard where he's
never going to play in but you know
back-to-backs but i think you can pick
and choose looking at the schedule where
you can find rest for LeBron especially
depending on who they're playing if
you're playing one of these teams where
you don't need his services there there
are certain games that you can pick and
choose where you can rest LeBron it
looks some of these other guys which I
think are starting to play well like you
know Caruso Kyle Koosman now Betty's
back you know from that injury he's
starting to shoot the ball better
they're gonna find ways to rest LeBron
while these other younger players do do
the load management of the work on the
floor along with Anthony Davis you got
pelicans and the Suns on Thursday night
any update on Zion Williamson I the
timetable for him to come back is still
unknown I think he hasn't picked up his
I think he's on the floor now actually
doing stuff but no contact but the
timetable is still unknown when Zion is
going to return and unfortunately the
Suns have been a pleasant surprise and
they don't even have DeAndre Aiden here
I like the mixture of having some
veterans there I thought they were just
a team that was way too young and it you
know they're there at least they have a
presence there they're not formidable
but you know what they're competitive
and let's give Monty Williams a lot of
credit here and you mentioned it a
mixture of veterans they took a bad loss
last night at home versus the Celtics
but they had they didn't have their
floor general in Ricky Rubio he was out
with back spasms and you know you got a
point guard in there that can lead these
young guys to me I've always loved the
game of Devin Booker I just think he's a
flat-out start a guy who can score the
basketball and defend you at the other
end but they do have a lot of young
players so if Rubio is back on Thursday
I think it makes them a different team
there are definitely one of my surprise
teams that's the way they're able to
score the basketball they are shooting
the basketball at a high clip they
didn't show that last night versus the
Celtics but again not having Rubio out
there on the floor I think really
affected him if he's back on
on thursday versus the pelicans i look
for a better outing from the sun's we
mentioned this a while ago in the show
McLovin in his first date one of his
first dates with his now-wife he went to
a psychic we were talking about how
psychics you know they give you that
random question where they go uh does
anybody in the room have a dog you know
and then they go oh my god he can read
our minds here never been to a psychic
i've never been to a second i i'm it's a
little spooky for me to do that because
you're right
i don't know if they're because if
they're real meat walking in the door
they already you know my whole life
story and that would freak me out
so no i've never been to a psychic or
you know a palm reader I'm just not into
that thing because it's a little too
it's it's too spooky for your boy were
you superstitious very very very very
grew up in the church so we look at mind
reader's and those type of people of the
devil Theodore did you sing in the choir
wrench I did not think the choir I can't
hold a note now I will tell you this I
am Luther Vandross in the shower don't
get me wrong now in the shower
wait are you skinny Luther or wait if I
close my eyes yeah yeah come on doesn't
that take you back
are you a better three-point shooter
than Luther was a singer I might be the
Luther van that means but we'll end it
at that
have fun in Phoenix reg thanks for
joining us that's Reggie Aloysius Miller
jr. the third
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]